it's hard to believe one of the biggest
television franchises tried to hide its
name for one reason or another all these
shows change titles some for the better
but others and not so much
it's easy to understand why Seinfeld is
seen today as one of the most popular
beloved and influential shows of the
past 50 years its unique brand of
fast-paced whip smart comedy and stories
at the fight convention became a
watershed moment in television that
shapes the landscape of sitcoms forever
famously a show about nothing it's
episodes were anything but ordinary
often revolving around a single everyday
moments like waiting for a seat at a
restaurant or buying a loaf of bread
however as quintessential series as
Seinfeld has become it didn't start out
that way when it premiered in July of
1989 there were a couple minor
differences in terms of characters and
even had a different title airing as the
Seinfeld Chronicles it's centered on New
York comedian Jerry Seinfeld and his
Surly friend George Costanza alongside a
wacky neighbor it still starred Jerry
Seinfeld Jason Alexander and Michael
Richards but the neighbor played by
Richards was named Kessler not Kramer
Julia louis-dreyfus's character Elaine
was nowhere to be found even more
surprising the pilot episode was
received negatively by audiences
thankfully the showrunners implemented a
few key changes simplified the title and
TV history was made
the 1980s might be the all-time best
decade for family sitcoms seeing the
birth of Classics like who's the boss
Growing Pains Family Ties and Full House
smack dab in the middle of these Classic
series was the Hogan Family the Sandy
duncan-led comedy followed an answer
arrives to take care of her nieces and
nephews after the death of her sister
however that premise isn't actually how
the series started it was originally
titled Valerie and started Valerie
Harper in the title role as a wife a
mother of three kids who struggles to
keep her busy life in order after the
show's second season though Harper was
unceremoniously fired following a
contract dispute until character was
killed off screen so in came Duncan as
Aunt Sandy and the show swapped out its
title running for another four
successful years as the Hogan Family
while Harper was forced to watch her own
show go on and find success without her
she would eventually get the last laugh
after the studio sued her trying to
claim to quit the series Harper
counter-sued in defiance and ultimately
went out when she was awarded 1.4
million dollars and lost wages in 1988.
arriving on the airwaves in 1975
Saturday Night Live became an instant
classic while SNL certainly wasn't the
first successful sketch comedy show to
air it's like conic cast of lesser known
Raw Talent made it decidedly different
from those that had come before what's
more the show was Far edgier than its
predecessors breaking down comedic
barriers and eventually becoming an
American cultural staple that turned
nearly its entire cast into stars with
such a well-chronicled history it's hard
to picture that the series ever went by
a different name but for its first
season it did the reason for the
discrepancy was that ahead of the
premiere SNL Studio learned that there
was already a variety show in
development called Saturday Night Live
to avoid legal problems or confusion
among the audience the sketch comedy
show launched as NBC's Saturday night
conveniently the other Saturday Night
Live ended after just one year so NBC
rebranded its late night series with a
title that we all know now and it's a
good thing too because SNL rolls off the
tongue a lot better than NSN
in the mid 90s the Star Trek franchise
was one of the biggest names on TV with
both Deep Space Nine and Voyager on the
air later in that decade though ratings
for both shows began to decline and it
felt like some franchise fatigue was
setting in in response to this downward
Trend a show winners made the decision
to wait until both series had ended
before launching another the result was
Star Trek Enterprise airing its first
episodes in the fall of 2001 the show
broke the status quo by being a
pre-course set in the early days of
human space exploration more than 100
years before Kirk and Spark went where
no one had gone before this is Captain
Jonathan Archer of the Starship
Enterprise
I don't need to tell you
whoever is that when the show first
began it broke the Norman another way by
removing Star Trek from the title
although it's difficult to imagine a
major franchise trying to distance
itself from its own name because the
Star Trek brand was fading in popularity
it was a strategic move at the time
verse for its first two seasons a series
was simply known as Enterprise it also
featured a pop song in the main title
sequence in place of the orchestral
themes of Prior Star Trek shows
unfortunately these changes to little to
attract a broader audience and by season
3 the show was officially retitled Star
Trek Enterprise with a new showrunner in
season 4 reviews improved but it wasn't
enough to save it a series was sadly
given the ax after its fourth season
John redson was one of the industry's
biggest sitcom Stars thanks to Three's
Company and this continuation Three's a
Crowd but when those came to an end he
struggled to find another popular series
starring in short-lived shows like
hooperman and hearts of fire in 2002
though the actor took the adult lead in
the sitcom eight simple rules where he
starred as a middle-aged father and
husband raising three kids future Big
Bang Theory Alum Kaylee Cuoco played
Bridget Ritter's on-screen daughter
however not everyone knows that Bridget
was once a titular character in the
series when the show first aired he had
the longer name eight simple rules for
dating my teenage daughter in its first
season the show ranked fairly well in
the ratings and seemed poised to become
a hit so in its second year the title
was simplified to make it a little less
clunky
a lot of that I mean I'm always like so
logical tragically Retta sudden death in
2003 forced a total overhaul and season
three saw the show we told to focus on
his character's father and brother
without Ritter however the sitcom just
couldn't stay afloat and eight simple
rules was canceled after its third
season
famous today for featuring a pair of
superstars before they were famous two
guys and a girl is pretty much exactly
what it says in the title a sitcom
centered on two male college buddies who
are friends with a young woman Deadpool
star Ryan Reynolds played alongside
Richard rukolo and trailer Howard as
Burke peace and Sharon respectively
additionally Nathan filliam played
Sharon's boyfriend Johnny though the
show was never a major hit it did air
for Four Seasons and remains one of the
most criminally under-appreciated 90s
sitcoms similar to 8 Simple Rules two
guys and a girl initially had a name
that was a lot longer and tougher to
Rattle off upon its release in 1998 the
series was called two guys a girl and a
pizza place and the plot of season 1
focused on Pete and Berger's co-workers
at a pizza restaurant and that decision
occurred because the show was actually
based on the real life experiences of
Creator Kenny Schwartz who worked at a
pizza joint while in college the title
wasn't shortened just to make it easier
to say either after the Show's first
season the pizza place premise was
de-emphasized and eventually digital
altogether this meant removing it from
the title and thus the show became two
guys and a girl
long before Freaks and Geeks there was
another iconic team comedy that made a
name for itself thanks for his offbeat
humor and unique storytelling style it
might be one of the most underrated 90s
TV shows and its name was Parker Lewis
Can't Lose the show followed a popular
high schooler and his Oddball friends as
they got themselves in and out of
trouble the series starred Corey Namek
as a titular Parker Lewis whose pension
for tongue-in-cheek monologues and
fourth wall breaking asides of folks
undeniable shades of the John Hughes
classic Ferris Bueller's Day Off aside
from a strange sense of humor one of the
things that made the show unique was its
fast-paced filming style which consisted
of Quick Cuts comic book angles and
cartoonish sound effects while this
aesthetic has helped it become a cold
classic it may have turned off some
audiences as many of the show's more
avant-garde elements were pushed aside
for its third season it was around that
time that the series also saw a name
change to the more straightforward
Parker Lewis
there have been countless Batman shows
over the years from Iconic entries at
the live-action series starring Adam
West to the legendary Batman the
Animated Series in more recent years the
TV explodes with the Dark Knight of
mostly revolved around the wider cast of
characters in Batman's world with
various series fixating on Police
Officer James Gordon Batwoman and the
Caped Crusaders Sidekicks it was only a
master of time before Alfred got his own
spin-off in 2019 fans got exactly that
with penny worth the origin of Batman's
butler a pre-quarter Gotham the series
explores the early life of Alfred
pennyworth when he worked as a James
Bond s agent running his own Security
Agency however the series then starts
out with that odd and worldly title
initially it had the much more pleasing
name of penny worth while it was a
simple enough Title by the show's second
season it seems the network was worried
that audiences didn't know the
significance of the name and how it is
related to Batman as a result they
changed the name of the series to
include the awkward subtitle for season
3 in order to make it completely clear
that yes this is the origin of Batman's
butler
no child of the 80s or 90s could forget
Saved by the Bell possibly the most
oddly celebrated teen show ever produced
it's esteem as an oddity because it
wasn't that stylish or slick nor was it
particularly good instead it was a
kitschy corny goofball comedy for the
whole family that was meme worthy long
before such a concept existed it's
centered on hip high schooler Zach
Morris his jock best friend AC Slater
nerdy Misfit Screech trendy Lisa Turtle
straight A student Jesse Spano and
cheerleader Kelly Kapowski when the show
got its start in 1989 however it was
something very different and not nearly
as appealing to teens as it later became
this was due to the fact that several
members of that cast weren't present yet
and the focus of the show wasn't even
the kids themselves instead the star of
the series was their teacher Miss Bliss
played by former Child Star Haley Mills
fittingly the original title of the show
was good morning Miss Bliss which was
how it was known for its entire first
season in fact Slater Jesse and Kelly
weren't yet part of the series and there
were several other who were there in
their place after 14 episodes the
students became the center of the
stories and Miss Bliss was written out
of her own show wow that's great that
had a poor staff take it after that the
series was renamed Saved by the Bell
continuing to air with this title for
Four Seasons
in 1960 Hollywood Legend Andy Griffith
got his own show a sitcom about a small
town sheriff named Andy Taylor future
Three's Company star Don Knott's
co-starred alongside him as Barney Fife
a bumbling goofball while a young Ron
Howard played Taylor's son Opie The Andy
Griffith Show was a Smash Hit becoming
one of the biggest shows of its ERA with
ratings to compete with Powerhouse
series like Bonanza and bewitched It
ultimately ran for more than a decade
depending on how you look at it the
exact length of China's show aired is
somewhat of the debate following Andy
Griffith's exit after season 8 the
series got a new name Mayberry RFD while
the change is sometimes considered the
beginning of a new series the fact that
most of the supporting cast from the
previous year returned means it's often
viewed as a continuation of the original
show names for the fictional town the
series was set in Mayberry RFD centered
on Ken Berry's character Town councilman
Sam Jones while many other recurring
characters returned throughout the
show's run Griffith along with his
co-stars Knutson Howard was noticeably
abs and aside from the occasional guest
appearance though the series shift away
from Andy Taylor could have killed the
show Mayberry RFD lived on for another
three seasons
foreign